-Hello and welcome, welcome,
welcome to
"The Tonight Show," everybody!
[ Cheering and applause ]
Well, guys, next week,
President Trump is planning
to leave the White House
for Palm Beach
on the morning
of Inauguration Day
and he's asked
for a large crowd
and a big,
military-style sendoff.
[ Laughter ]
Yeah.
Trump wants a big farewell.
He's even requested
a red carpet, live music,
and Rudy Giuliani
to be launched from a cannon.
[ Laughter and applause ]
It's going to be quite a day.
A bunch of Trump supporters
in Washington, D.C.
What could possibly go wrong?
[ Laughter ]
That's right, Trump wants
to assemble a large crowd
to remind everyone
of his legacy --
completely ignoring
the coronavirus.
[ Laughter ]
Trump's basically
that annoying friend
who keeps dropping hints that
they want a surprise party.
[ Laughter ]
[ As Trump ]
Can't believe Wednesday is
my last day.
[ Laughter ]
And I've been really getting
into listening to vinyl records.
[ Laughter ]
Yep, Trump wants a big send-off,
but, as of now,
the only thing they have planned
is an awkward office party
with a cake that says...
[ Laughter and applause ]
Yeah, Trump is expecting
a big military presence.
Officials would be like,
"Yes, sir, the, uh,
Space Force is doing
a s-space parade.
You just can't see it from here.
[ Laughter ]
Apparently, Trump wants
all his favorite
military officials
to be there --
generals, colonels,
captains, admirals.
I think we actually
have a photo.
Yeah, there you go.
[ Laughter and applause ]
Imagine what he'd ask for
if he won the election.
[ As Trump ]
I wanted stealth fighters.
I want zebras.
I want a cement truck
demolition derby.
[ Laughter ]
Really been getting
into vinyl records.
[ Laughter ]
Listening.
This is interesting --
since Biden and Trump will be
in different places
for the inauguration,
they each will have a suitcase
holding the nuclear codes.
But, once Biden takes the oath,
Trump's codes will deactivate.
Yeah.
What's crazy is that the guy
we don't trust to be on Twitter
is still carrying around
the nuclear codes.
[ Laughter ]
There's no way
Trump still has a briefcase
with the actual nuclear codes.
I'm sure, years ago,
someone switched it out
with one of the briefcases
from "Deal or No Deal"
[ Laughter ]
[ As Trump ]
32.
[ Laughter and applause ]
Meanwhile, I heard that Trump
is still deciding
whether he'll carry on
the presidential tradition
of writing a letter
to his successor
and leaving it
on the Resolute Desk.
I'm not sure how much wisdom
Trump has to offer.
So far, Trump's only
"advice" to Biden is
to call dibs on the
Lincoln Bedroom before Jill.
[ Laughter ]
"No, no, we actually
sleep in the same --"
[ Laughter ]
My guess is,
instead of a letter,
Trump's going to pull
a "Sex and the City"
and leave a Post-It that says...
[ Laughter ]
But this is nice --
Melania is leaving Jill Biden
the same letter Michelle Obama
left for her.
Isn't that sweet?
[ Laughter ]
[ Applause ]
Isn't that sweet?
Speaking of Biden moving
into the White House,
there are reports
that he may have to leave
his Peloton bike behind,
since it has a camera
and microphone
that could be hacked.
Even hackers were like,
[ Slavic accent ]
"If you think we want to watch
old man sweat and grunt
to REO Speedwagon,
you're very mistaken."
[ Laughter ]
Actually, I forgot
the White House even had a gym.
For the last four years,
it's just been a place
to hide from the president.
[ Laughter ]
Some sports news --
the NFL playoffs
continue this weekend
and one matchup everyone
is excited about is
Tom Brady versus Drew Brees,
the two oldest quarterbacks
in the league.
They're already wishing
each other good luck.
Today, Brady called Brees
and was like, "Break a hip."
[ Laughter ]
Yeah, instead of Bud Light
and Doritos commercials,
there are going to be just
a bunch of commercials
for the UroClub.
[ Laughter ]
-Hell!
-Yeah, those guys are so old,
when they see Patrick Mahomes,
they just pinch his cheeks.
[ Laughter ]
Alright, listen to this --
I saw is
the 20th anniversary
of Wikipedia.
At least, I think it is.
I'm not sure because I read it
on Wikipedia.
[ Laughter ]
It's amazing --
in just 20 years,
Wikipedia has written
20 trillion high school essays.
[ Laughter ]
Meanwhile, Tom Brady
and Drew Brees were like,
"Back in my day,
if we want to know something,
we had to Ask Jeeves."
[ Laughter ]
And, finally,
police in Argentina
raided a swingers party,
but, when they showed up,
the swingers thought
the cops were strippers.
[ Laughter and applause ]
It didn't help when the cops
were like, "Alright,
we can do this the easy way
or the hard way."
[ Laughter ]